this is the worst kept secret like we've
known this is gonna happen for a long
time
Harmonix recently came out they've
announced rock band 4 is happening but
we actually got to play this one which
we still haven't seen with rock band we
don't know whether that's what's gonna
be different about that Guitar Hero is
is really taking things in in a pretty
different direction with with their
guitar itself like it it is not laid out
with this traditional five button layout
you have three keys on the bottom and
three keys on the top and at first I
remember looking at that and going this
is gonna be way too simple you'll you
have three and like it's six total but
just either on top or on on the bottom
like this this layout seems really easy
but but it's not yeah and I mean and
keep them out also right like there's no
more like high neck moves at all like
your hands just in one place and it
makes sense they were pretty adamant
about like you know these this is the
future right for Guitar Hero and one of
the main Pickers as far as like the
layout is like power chords are like
actually holding down a finger and doing
combinations that way now you have a
three button layout but because it's a
two by three grid you're actually making
makeshift chords the strumming is the
same system it's just a click for beat
they still come down the neck the exact
same but the the idea of kind of
creating chords now changes it up a bit
I literally felt my brain breaking
inside my head but once you get it what
you understand it and for me it took
like about halfway through the song like
it just clicks and it feels really good
it's still it's really fun and
challenging in a very different way and
like sometimes your your your hand
doesn't I wouldn't say it feels like
you're making chords but the the
configuration makes you think enough
that it then feels fresh again
what they're also trying to change up is
is that experience of stepping out on
stage like when you're playing rock band
you're always staring at avatars that
you created or Guitar Hero as well like
they just had pre-made avatars and kind
of what I mean there's not a lot you can
do with that the focus is on the music
and in this way they I think they are
they're trying to make you feel like
you're actually in the band you're in
the crowd you're seeing it from the
first-person perspective of a guitar
player and you're looking out of the
crowd even at the beginning like I was
also skeptical of when they're like
we're trying to get that that stage
fright feeling like you do feel it a
little bit when you're walking out with
it unless your band mates you see like
hundreds of people thousands of people
spread out before you're like oh this is
this is a little bit of timid ating
yeah changing the perspective is a huge
huge change this is the first time that
you're actually to me ever interested in
looking at the backgrounds before when
we used to play with your little punk
avatars I didn't like looking at them I
didn't care now you're a little bit more
interested to see the crowd
I will admit I found the intros a little
overdone and I was already by the second
time hoping that they would have a skip
button and they're a little long and
drawn-out I don't really care about
pretending that much that I am this rock
star but it does give you that feeling
gives you the butterflies in your
stomach that you're going out onstage
and you're about to perform in front of
a very large audience and you have the
band that's playing along with you like
they're they're actors they're not like
an actual band but each one is synced to
to play with you as it is if they're a
real band and when you start to [ __ ] up
they they and they boo you they like
that what do you do a dude yeah there's
a Steadicam and they basically play the
song once for the good and then once the
bad so then like basically intercut that
like you're doing poorly it's gonna ship
to the bad version of the baby there's
kind of like a dream sequence of trips
over to like Oh everything's shitty you
were not looking at those backgrounds
nobody is looking at those backgrounds
you're focusing on on the neck of the
guitar and the chords you're about to
play but it doesn't mean the people
around you don't appreciate it and if
you do catch a glimpse of it during a
break of a song it's interesting to see
it and I find I find it a little bit
more interesting a little bit more
dynamic when I'm playing the game so I
thought that was pretty cool but the
entire basis of a game like this is all
about the music like if it doesn't have
good music it's not going to work so
rock band I think has has a pretty good
idea for what they're doing all of their
own songs that you've ever downloaded
are gonna work on rock band 4 with
Guitar Hero they never really had that
same passionate fan base were just like
constantly buying songs so they're
taking a kind of interesting approach
for this with something called Guitar
Hero lives whether there are gonna be
game songs that work on the disc and we
saw some of those they're each gonna
have that band that's built into them
but in terms of DLC instead of making
you purchase individual songs apparently
you're gonna be able to tune in
and select songs as they're playing some
they're really unclear about how the
monetization them that's gonna work that
which is a little bit scary but we'll
probably hear some more about that any
free but there are going to be some free
channels and there are going to be some
premium channels basic cable and then
premium for those really interested in
music subscribers how they explained it
was yeah you can do on-demand you can
pick a song and start off and playing it
instead of the first person perspective
as the campaign or single player it's
straight up the music video official
music video for that song so you can
either start on-demand or as these
channels kind of like blind up was you
just hop in and there are the other
players on the left and who's doing the
best it's kind of like a fight to get to
the top type of competitive play okay
for this game is that they have a pretty
interesting model for just buying the
basic standard game itself and it sounds
like it's going to be not only on the
platform but you would expect it will be
a mobile game standalone and apparently
you just plug it into your TV and play
it no different than you would as if you
bought it on Xbox one yeah Activision
has experience with doing something
really similar with Skylanders where it
is there is a base game that has a
peripheral and in Skylanders case it's
you know what you plug your your little
character into in Guitar Hero's case is
gonna be the guitar but the game is
gonna be the same price no matter what
you're basically paying for the hardware
I don't know if people are gonna feel
the same way about buying an iPad or a
mobile version of game as they do about
a ps4 version though like I think that
might be a point of contention when you
look on the store shelf and you go well
is it gonna be $60 whether I buy the ps4
version or whether I buy the iPad
version effects that might be a little
bit of problem so unfortunately no
matter what how many of these sweet
dusty guitars you have in your basement
or closet you do not get to take them
out because you will have to buy the new
guitar in addition to the new game but
do you think that this is this setup is
something that kind of sells it for you
a little bit I never got rid of my
guitars they're still sitting in my
basement so when rock band announced
like all your DLC is gonna work all of
you
old guitar hardware's gonna work I'm
like oh that's cool I don't have to buy
all of this new stuff the thing that's a
bigger break for me is that it's only
guitar it is called Guitar Hero I mean
it's funny you'd think you know maybe
even just bass if you get a tin and I
mean it wouldn't be that much different
just like single notes but yeah I
thought it was pretty great I think what
really like turned me on was for the
live mode was putting up a music video
like even if you don't even want to play
guitar hero you can still kind of enjoy
it for that matter like the avatars were
kind of like hokey and repetitive but
now you get like an actual music video
and that was cool it starts like a party
aspect like that really sets well yeah
having that music video playing in the
background just people can come up and
pick up a guitar and the way the
channels work of just kind of be able to
hop into a song I think it's always
contingent on the music to me and they
are going to hold out I believe until
III to release that sweet lift guitar
hero and rock band are the games that
introduced me to so many bands and songs
that I didn't even know about it till
then so I'm also just excited to have a
game that's gonna introduce me to new
music that yeah I feel like it kind of
opens me up to experiences I haven't had
before well thanks a lot guys I think
it's time to get back to work yeah I got
a star Pakistan again practice
especially you
well